j'accueille maintenant axelle laffont
ces normes affirme bohringer il parlait
chantons macgyver oui j'ai beau
challenge vous savez pas ce qu'on peut
aussi avancer bien 5
oui oui on avait habillé en banque non
j'étais en punk je vais demander quelle
est ici connaissez le la plus la chanson
la plus connue sex pistols ça il m'a
répondu c'était un access de queens
grass et bien ils ont passé pas la bonne
mais bon c'est un art kindy ok mais bon
c'est pas mal pour un mec qui a été
premier ministre bien c'est pas grave
alors accès de la force depuis le 4
septembre 2000 vous fait la pluie et le
beau temps tout le monde vous le dis ça
sur canal+ en présentant la météo d'une
façon assez peu conventionnelle aux
alentours de 19h20 dans nulle part
ailleurs voilà c'est ça c'est donc les
jasées maintenance qui veut mater en
fait ce qui est très drôle avec vous si
vous parlez jamais ni du temps ni de la
température et tout ceci est prétexte à
à sketches et on va voir à quoi ça
ressemble